hello ladies and gents in this video
we're going to look at imue
from
a pretty far-out scope i want to talk
about the important sources and things
you need to know about it
and what it can do
and that's mainly going to be the first
part of this video
the second part we're actually going to
code up an example from scratch
just so that you can
get a better understanding of how to put
it into your project
if you're newer to this sort of stuff
all right so let's have a look at i am
gooey i want this to be an all-inclusive
video that covers as much and as broad
as possible in a short amount of time so
that you have a great jumping off point
if you're new to this
or have a better understanding of things
if you're just trying to
understand more about i am gooey a
google image search of i am gui reveals
some popular use cases and examples
i would highly recommend checking it out
if
you're questioning whether it's the
right gui for you
and also i have a few video links that
i'll show you shortly but let's look at
some of these
and just kind of take in the options
available
[Music]
as you can see
ubisoft uses it for development of their
games sometimes
but they also have a game ui that ships
with that but you can see the developers
are tracking things
and
modifying variables
with imui
wow you can just do so much
really for me to get into this it's
going to take way too long
to tell you every little option
pretty much
all the main features
of a ui that you would want
are capable of from text to buttons to
radio buttons to color pickers
sliders drop downs you name it i am
gooey can do it so
if this is the kind of thing you need to
add to your coding project
i'm going to show you how to do it with
well pretty much anything but let's look
at a few more sources just to explain
why i am gooey is so good and why it is
so popular i'm willing to bet most of
you have heard of casey moratori he's a
programmer he does a lot of content on
youtube so you can look him up but he's
been doing this for a long time
and he tends to
generally know what he's talking about
if he tells you he knows what he's
talking about
and in 2005
he wrote an intermediate mode graphical
user interfaces blog and did a video on
it that's about 40 minutes long in this
video it covers a lot of the kind of why
you would use this type questions so i'd
highly recommend that if you're still
questioning why you would use imqe but
you can
see
just the conclusion about it if you're
arguing about it you probably don't
understand it very well there's not a
lot to argue about which is a very high
thing to say of it
and why would you say that well you can
watch this and kind of get an
understanding but basically
it is incredibly efficient
and it doesn't take much work one of the
main features of imgui is that it
attaches to whatever
rendering back-end you set up
opengl vulcan
directx and a bunch of the in between
it can
attach to any of them with
special what they call binding files
but those are essentially just
little functions to set it up to what
you're currently using
we'll talk about bindings more here
shortly
once we get into the walkthrough
but the point of that is since it binds
directly to your graphical interface of
choice or your graphical rendering setup
of choice it's already incredibly
efficient and doesn't have much overhead
so enough of these screenshots
let's look at
where you can learn this
one great source i found that was
incredibly helpful
was
a
article in a video
by uh what's this guy's name jerry
witlas
who works for the conan team now conan
is a package manager that helps you
install libraries
kind of like bc package manager and a
whole bunch of others there are quite a
few of these but conan
is a cross-platform one
that is pretty easy to use
we tend to use vc pkg on this channel a
lot but we could just as well use conan
all the time and it wouldn't be a whole
lot different so he does have a video
here that goes over
the basics
and welcome to another screen and it is
quite good it's only six minutes long it
tells you the
the basics of getting it going with
opengl
and provides some code
that has it already ready
to go for a jumping off point
so
if you kind of just want to get going
quick
this would be a good video to just watch
a couple of these sections here
to kind of cover the elephant in the
room or to point it out
there are a million different options
for how to get started here
like we already sort of talked about you
can use any of these package managers if
you're already using one great just run
its install and get it set up
these are just two of them
but there are
there's literally so many package
managers that it's impossible to keep
track of them
but there are a few core
well-known ones so i would recommend
using using one of those you can find i
am gooey on github
you do a search for dear i am gooey or
am gooey but generally you're going to
look for the most popular one by the
actual developer i guess it took a deer
in front of it i'm not sure
there it
is by okra nut i think that's how he
says it
this is the main repo
and it is
the
the main source
okay so let's talk about what we
actually need from here and a little bit
about how it works
but we're going to see in here some
examples and some back ends that's
mostly what we want the back ends are
what handle
setting it up for whatever you want
these are what they often call bindings
so you can see there's opengl ones and
there's a bunch of other stuff directx
glfw fusion glfw
and opengl you just grab those that's
all you need you need these few files
now you don't absolutely need these
because you can go take a peek at them
and you can see
exactly how they work
they basically just run this function so
you can go look at this function and
these are things you've probably done
before while getting rendering up and
going
okay so that's the the back-ends there's
examples
well where's the source i think it's
just right here
i'm gui.h
this has all the main code
and i'm not sure exactly where it's at
but basically you'll see in here some
very basic shaders
it handles all the shader back in and
they pretty much just use little squares
and a couple triangles to do all this
stuff also while i was doing research
here i learned that
there is a granny animation studio which
is essentially
i think
the animation setup that got pulled into
unreal engine because it's now owned by
epic games
uh rad game tools
but this was mentioned in that casey
moratorio article where he said he was
working on an interface for this and
that's when he got to the intermediate
mode stuff and then i started looking at
this and realized hey got pop by unreal
or whatever happened
i don't know pretty cool stuff though
it's a neat to see that other people uh
work on stuff and get their tools kind
of bought by big companies if they're
that good so it's just inspiration to
try to be better and don't worry about
all the other things it's all about how
good it ends up being but with a good
interface
your tools are much more clear
and you have a much better shot okay
back to imgui repo here so you could
clone this
and use it that way and there are some
tutorials down through here
of how to kind of get it working but
let's go ahead and just code it up from
scratch
[Music]
i could use cmake or visual studio
project management i'm going to go with
cmake i think here in this case so all
we're going to do here is launch visual
studio
the latest version as of today and it'll
probably be the same in the future
we're going to hit create a new project
we're going to choose
cmake
i think it's in here
this should make it cross-platform
enough to be usable by anyone
and i'm just going to call this
imue
example
okay it has created the project and we
have some defaults
it gives us a top level cmake
that adds
a project
and a subdirectory
and the subdirectory is where we're
going to be doing our work because
essentially this top level cmake is for
in case you're having multiple projects
because we can make a new folder with a
new subdirectory and a new cmake
but that's beyond the scope of this
particular project
or in this
tutorial so it gives us a header for our
includes basically and it gives us a
main
i think we're going to get rid of this
header here and we're going to maybe do
this in a class so we're going to go add
new file maybe add new item has class no
there's no class here
so we just have to manually do it and
that's fine we could just
go
well we don't want to call it imqe
because that's already taken so we need
a better name i'm going to call this
class use
i am viewing let's give it some proper
endings dot cpp
and we're going to make a header of that
as well and now we can start a class
let's start with the header
we put pragma once at the top so it
doesn't get double included anywhere
and we're going to include
i am gui dot h
it doesn't see it of course yet and
that's because we need to set it up with
our project here there are multiple ways
to do that
and i've covered this in other videos so
i'm not going to get into it in great
detail
essentially
we just need to pick a method
where we either grab it from github or
use one of those package managers
in this case we're going to make a
a local install of it from our vc
package stuff we can just as well use
conan in that video earlier explains how
to do it with conan
but in this case we're just going to at
the top level add a new file called
vcpkg.json
and we're going to put in all the
library info
here now this is going to look something
like this you want a name
for your project and we're just going to
call this one
imbue example
and we also oh we need a comma there we
need a version
and we could do version string if we
want to do more than just numbers
but let's just do versions so we can
call this
one
dot zero
and last but not least we need some
dependencies
and then
we put them within square brackets
and all we need on this one is i am
gooey
oh but wait we need a windowing system
let's also grab glf w3
but what render are we going to use
well i guess we'll just use
opengl because i know how to do that one
quickly
so i'm going to bring in
glad which brings in opengl headers
okay so now when we go to build our
project
or go to generate our project it's going
to grab these libraries from vc pkg
this should happen automatically as long
as you have
a pvc pkg installed and as i hit
generate there
some stuff starts happening
and it begins
grabbing all the files that we specified
from the
json
it tells you how to use them
oh let's go back to
wherever that was
we need to see the list oh it's down at
the bottom output
okay
yeah there's some errors in our code we
already know that but we basically need
to put these
all in our
cmake files so we're just going to copy
those
let me just dock this uh maybe over here
and we'll close this thing
all right so we go
to the project we want those in and
just put them in here
i can put them below
and we can get rid of all these comments
if we want
they're just for
new users in case you don't know what
this stuff is
but
that's beyond the scope all right
why doesn't let me delete line one i
don't know there it goes
okay so there's glad
and let's put in glfw
okay this click isn't working like there
we go i'm just hacking it together real
quick here
and there we go
yeah it's ugly the spacing's wrong but
it should work
so this just tells it to link it to our
project basically
it will find the package because we have
them
set up
here with a place to get them
and we're just running what it tells us
to run so now when we generate
nothing really is going to change
because we need to add it to our code
but what should happen is we can now
include
oh i gotta change the name in this the
name of the project
yes that would help a lot
we're seeing some more errors
and it looks like it doesn't like
something about add executable
so we need to
debug our cmake file a little bit
and it looks like it didn't add
these new files here
we're getting rid of this.h so let's
just change that
and then we need a dot h for this
because we're going to build this in a
little class
that way we can isolate it from the rest
of our project
if we want
this is an optional way of doing it you
could just do it all in a big main
okay now this did grab the debug version
of the libraries
if we want to grab the release version
using this method we go to manage
configuration up here
hit the plus button find x64 release
and don't change anything else we don't
really need to the default should be
fine
save
and exit this file
and now you'll see in this drop down we
have an x64 release
and if we hit generate on this release
it will grab
the release version of these libraries
we're going to stick with debug for now
and it looks like it's happy
it did find
i am gui which is their main header
now you can go and see
all these libraries of course this is
sort of on a different topic but if you
go to
open folder and file explorer
you can see
that we're going to have a list of
installed stuff
pcpkg installed
and you can see all the libraries it
includes and here you find imqe
which is a dot h file and all the other
stuff it is grabbed
for you
from this vc pkj json there's the lives
and i think this should be lowercase
okay now we can make a class so let's do
it
we're going to just put some core
methods in here
publicly we're going to have
a
init
an update
on render
and last but not least
we will have
a
maybe this least
this update
we can make a virtual function
and the reason for this is
we want to be able to override this
but maybe we want a default of a hello
world in it
we can also override
the init
for different
renders
stuff like that a lot of thought could
go into how you want to do this but
essentially you're done you're going to
need an init you're going to need an
update you're going to need a render
and a shutdown
so we're just going to do it in this
method
so all we need to do is just build all
these functions and then call them in
our main
there's our main
we want to change this include
there we go
declare it
making a knit
i'm kind of doing the front end first
and then i'm going to put all the back
in together
so you want to knit
and
then you want to go into a while loop
and you want to go
update
and render
and then when it leaves the loop
he wants
i'm gui
shut down
but of course
we need a window
that's what we're going to use glfw for
now we could
do this in a lot of different ways
i'm just going to do it directly
and we're going to use opengl so we also
want to include blad
and we're just going to set up a glfw
window
i'm actually going to copy and paste
some code for this because i don't feel
like typing it all out but this is from
the early example
from the conan
page that i showed earlier on
so essentially we're just going to use a
little bit of this
and you can see he has a main with a
setup window
this should work perfectly fine for us
so we're going to get
up to
i think about here and that's where
things start to change for us
uh we'll grab up to here but we're not
using glue we're using glad so we're
gonna have to change a little bit there
glue is just another version
uh he has a set error callback we're not
going to worry about that for now
we're just going to try to emit glw
i'm going to get rid of this apple code
because i don't particularly care
and
we'll use
we could use core profile
these don't matter a whole lot for us
actually in this case
we'll just leave it how it is
we'll change this to example
now we just need to
set the context
with glad
the easiest way to do this is well we're
going to get rid of this code
is to just use the glide loader to get
the proc address
from glfw now essentially what this does
is it tells opengl to draw to this
window currently
and you do have to make sure you do this
context current first
and at this point
we're pretty much set up we have a
screen width and height that we are
going to get from the window and set the
viewport to that
and that should grab 1280 by 720
and set the viewport to that we only
need to do that once
and now we're going to declare our use
imgui object
initialize it and do update render loops
on it but now we can do while window is
open
where our window should close
on our window
which we named just window here
but we want to put a knot here
so we want to stay in this loop while
it's not closing if it is closing then
we're exiting
all right so now we just build this
stuff
and i'm going to show you how to do that
we're to the meat and potatoes here
at this current point
it will probably build but it's probably
going to say undefined functions for
these
so let's just make them blank functions
for now and we will fill them out
shortly
and of course if you don't want to use
class
you can literally put
do this the same way except just put the
code here wherever we're calling these
functions
i like doing it in a class because this
allows for later expansion and as you'll
see there's a reason we make this update
virtual
and it's uh
well i'll show you
actually now i think about it it might
not be the best way to do this virtual
because
well let me think about it a little
okay at this point we are ready to
initialize which means we need to bind
it to opengl now the imgui code
which we can go look at here again let's
open
this out folder or check it out
open in file explorer
and we have the installs
now the installs
will have all this vcp kg stuff
but we don't see the imgui bindings that
say for opengl or gfw
so we do need to grab those
so how do you get the bindings auto
include
well it looks like that is possible
so there is some info you can find
online about i am gui
and how it's included in
your package manager it's it's going to
be different for every package standards
is the conan video i linked earlier
earlier shows you how to do it on conan
but on this you're essentially going to
have to use
whichever binding you need to grab that
you can also just copy and paste the
code from github and put in your project
but this will be a more automatic so
we're going to want opengl 3 dash
binding and
glfw dash binding
so we're going to need to tell it to
grab those when you grab imgui
and we're going to be doing that in this
vcpkg
json
so to do that
we surround
the dependency with these new brackets
and we make sure we
give it the name and the features
so imdui needs to be expanded to this
new block
to get the bindings you want and you can
see over here in the output when we
generate it
it detected all that and it got us what
we need
and we should see it now in the alt
build
where it builds all our libraries
so let's have a look and make sure
that's all there
there they are
and now we have the bindings ready to go
so that we can set it up for what we
need now of course
just to be a hundred percent clear if
you're using vulcan or directx
you grab the bindings for those if
you're using allegro or sdl you grab the
bindings for those we're grabbing the
binding specific to what we need it's
one of the great things about i'm qe
is it has all these ready to go and if
you look at them you could rewrite them
in a very simplistic form for your
specific case
but these just kind of have all the code
ready to go for you which is
of course nice when you're
in a hurry and trying to get your
project done and not too worried about
every little technicality
so now that we have our bindings and it
generated successfully
we are done there
and now what we can do is start actually
using it
and using everything
since we have an imgui init
we are going to put all the code into
there
we just need to pull in these bindings
that we need
this one
not sure if we need the loader
let's start which is just these
so in our init code that's going to get
called first
we're going to put some
some basic stuff
i'm going to do a little copy paste save
time but we basically want i am gui
check version
and we want pineviewe create context
and we also want
get i o
i am ue
io
uh i might be wrong about the i o thing
i don't know if we actually need it yet
but let's just leave it there
all right now we need our render and
platform specific stuff
which is going to be
these here
as you can see this needs to know about
the glfw window
so we actually need to pass that in
which if you think about it makes a lot
of sense
because
when we're just walking through this
code here it needs to know which one
which window
is set up for it
and it's simply this one we created here
and if you go look at the code
it will make even more sense
just need to make sure we update this
file
very good
and this version
it looks like we should probably pass
that along too
so we'll just copy this
there and then when we go to call it
we'll just pass that along as well
you might complain about some kant stuff
yeah probably is going to
so let's put const here
very well
and that should do it for the init we
could also put any preferences here
like style or things like that
we're just going to set style dark
and now it's programmer update
let's go to this loop and take a look at
it one thing we're going to need here is
glw pull events this basically checks
for key bindings and clicks and
stuff happening through the window
we're not setting up too many callbacks
but we at least need to
pull events
so that we can get our clicks and stuff
for uh i am gooey
this also
allows us to actually close the window
because without pulling events that
never knows when you close it
alright so let's go ahead and program
this update and render
and i'm still using a lot of this code
from the jfrog example
that i've referenced earlier
as we can see here
he does a clear color on
opengl
and some stuff here
let's look just for the imgui stuff we
see a new frame and a clear frame
so we want to call opengl's new frame
shell w's new frame
and then the i am giving new frame
this essentially
starts a whole new frame so let's put
that in there
we could have this as its own function
or we could just put it at the top of
the update
to be honest it probably makes more
sense to have this as its own function
but i'm not actually 100 sure and it
might be use case specific
i think in our case for now let's just
go ahead and make another function
called new frame
void
new
that's going to call all of that stuff
for us
there we go
and then in our update over here
we can call that right here
so that just makes it easy to keep our
update separate from that new frame
now at this point
in the update
we want to put in all the code for the
interface we want
they've got some code here
and
we could copy it exactly
but they've got some specific functions
it's tied to
looks like to draw the conan logo that's
actually pretty cool
maybe i will do that but
just to show the example
yeah sure why not let's do it so we're
going to need from
right here where it says i'm gooey end
all the way to
where it says begin
just to show you how versatile this is
but wait there's more we do need this
render
function and it looks like they're
setting transforms on a shader
so you see how you could do this
uh you could
have it set a float value and then send
that to your shader pretty cool thing
we are not going to do that
uh so we're going to get rid of this
whole block actually we'll just render
the conan logo for now but you can
literally put anything in here with the
beginning to end and what you want
in the center there
i just want to see this uh how it trolls
this this is kind of a cool thing
where is somewhere in here here it is
so rather than bring it over then well
we could bring over the entire function
for a second why not
and we'll let's just put it at the top
of this file or up here
don't do this this is bad practice
uh but
it you kind of get the point here
probably now we need this render and
shutdown
let's go ahead and get those in there
and the render is pretty straightforward
you just render for your context
they've got it where is it
right here
let's call render and then open gl draw
data on the draw data
from imqe
and then and shut down
last but not least here we'll just put
all this clean up stuff in here
and at this point
it should actually run
i don't see any squigglies
no squigglies
no squigglies
x64 debug current document let's go
there were some conversion warnings
but it looks like everything went okay
we don't see much so what's going on
here
so glfw swap buffers
is obviously what we need at the end
here
it basically just says draw what's on
the screen
and now we are drawing what's on the
screen who would have thought
so over here we have the default i'm gui
now you can see it's collapsed but you
have a little draggable thing
and there is the conan logo they've
managed to draw it with the vector
graphics
that imgui allows which is super cool
you just use an imdraw list so you can
literally draw anything
i'm willing to bet someone has made a
tool that generates this type of code
for you but that's just one of the many
options so let's have some fun with this
gui and start adding a bunch of stuff
because that this is essentially all you
do is you just add a bunch of stuff
and i don't mean literally a bunch of
stuff you add what's
makes sense for your project for us
clearly we don't need this
code logo it's a cool little experiment
we'll leave the code here maybe
and i'll leave a link to his repo
but ultimately we want to
make our own stuff so this is where it
gets really fun the setups all done now
the fun begins
and you can look at examples and you can
just pile them in this update you put
whatever you want in this update about i
am gooey and i want to show you another
super cool trick
at the end
how to do one more cool thing but for
now
let's practice putting things in here so
your assignment would be
to just copy paste stuff in here at this
point
for whatever you want to show on your
screen
so we could say
i am
ue
let our auto completion
kick in maybe
insert text
i don't know i'll find something
the easiest way to do this is probably
to just google stuff
there are so many examples
and so many things you can do
let's google i am gui examples
oh well there's one on the master repo
that has examples for a bunch of stuff
let's see what they've got in here
well they've got all the setup stuff
we've already handled all that so no
need to look at that but here they go
they have some imgui begin and end stuff
and they have some statics
so you typically want your
variables to either be global or static
if they're coming in here that's not
always true
but it could be a good rule of thumb
uh it looks like they have some
additional functionality set up i guess
we're gonna delete those because we
don't have this
in here
and
we need a clear color
ah okay we'll just put that in here as a
static
static float
uh all static does in case you don't
know is it makes it persist
uh through the function so normally
anytime this function is called any
variables are created but static
function or static variables are only
created once thus it actually works
properly
it would just reset its value every
single time if it wasn't static which is
not going to work well for a color
picker because it's just going to reset
the color all the time
but uh yeah this needs to be three
floats so
that there should work
it's angry that it's not initialized but
it's okay our color picker will change
it
and there we go this this should just
work
i don't know if we actually need these
but those are probably variables yeah
actually we do okay
uncomfortable okay so let's go ahead and
build and run this
so hopefully by now you're starting to
see how you can
show and edit variables and pretty much
design interfaces to your content as we
showed at the beginning of this video
and with this i am gui should start to
become useful for you
i hope this explained enough for you to
get going
no matter what build setup you're using
what os you're on what rendering
platform you're on
this should give you enough info if not
feel free to ask questions
okay and one last thing i want to look
back to why i was talking about this
being virtual
uh earlier
and it's because
well i guess it's a
it's a bit to explain but basically
it's for expanding this class because
obviously you can initialize it with
different things and you could put in a
bunch of different knits here
or or
put in like
trying to think of a good way to say it
but basically if you want this to be
usable for everything in a proper
brief run-in for i'm gooey as if it
doesn't have enough of a front end
already
you could essentially abstract poor and
if you're doing certain methods of your
own you could override
only the ones you want
with virtual
for example
let's go back to our main
and up at the top here rather than make
a new file i'm just going to make
a new version of that class that we just
built and i'm going to call this one
custom
custom i'm qe
and i'm going to inherit from
i could spell right and i'm going to
inherit from use
i am gui
uh publicly
so we're in public here
everything's public anyway we're just
keeping it simple
and now we can
make our own virtual we can make our own
functions
there's no pure virtuals
pure virtuals must be overridden this
one's optional
so maybe for example we just have like
a hello world
as this base one
and in this one we want our
virtual void
update
override and this will essentially
override that function with whatever we
want
so maybe we do that one here
now let's just put this whole thing in
here
that's just something you can do with
classes in general
obviously not required
but it gives you an idea of
some places where you might want to
override
so maybe the space one okay let's just
put just a solo world nothing else
and an end
so now the base one only has
it's gonna call this one right we're
just gonna get a little hello world
thing that's it
but now we can
if we make our own
we'll just call this one here
and we just say hey we're using that one
update is nx oh i have it private i need
to put
classes default to private so if you
want your stuff to be public you got to
be sure to write it in there
and now it should be happy so now using
this one
we get
what we overwrote it with so just that's
why i was thinking maybe virtual but
the reality is if you're going to do
something like this it's going to
require more expansion than just that
but hey that's one one way to do it
and it's a nice sample of that code all
right so yeah hopefully this helps you
get imbue going and helps you understand
it a little better
there are a ton of examples online
so feel free to have a gander just
google search i'm doing samples or i am
gooey and you'll find lots of different
things lots of people providing their
code about how they've done specific
things
and uh yeah it's a great way to get an
interface
on any project you're doing basically
with any of the languages we talk about
here on this channel
and it requires very minimal effort you
don't have to write all this code
yourself you can just kind of put it in
there it's very efficient
and check out those articles i linked if
you're curious about more
thank you all for watching and for the
support it really does mean a lot
i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you